okay so there's this hormone called
growth hormone it's the main anti-aging
hormone the problem is as you age it
goes down and by the time you hit age 50
it's it's pretty low so you want to do
everything you can to increase growth
hormone and i'm going to explain a way
to boost it by 2
000 percent if you would exercise
intensely you would only increase growth
hormone by 450 percent but if you were
to do intermittent fasting you can
increase growth hormone by 2
percent it's not even about
eating certain foods or whatever it's
basically intermittent fasting so you
want to at least do 16 hours but work up
to about 20 hours of fasting and then
you can eat in that four hour window i
like like me i'll eat it like one
o'clock and then maybe at five sometimes
at four and that gives me that those
four hours of 20 of like call your
eating window and you have 20 hours of
fasting so that's the way to increase
growth among